uh this from matt mobley
from facebook he wants to know in the
movie gravity why did george clooney
have to let go now you're gonna have to
fill me in on this cause i didn't see
the movie so i don't know you want to
cover your ears
i'm a big boy you know i'm going to see
it anyway but now he goes on to say the
russian shuttle
sandra bullock and george clooney were
going at the same philosophy same
velocity right no force was required
for him to hold on yeah i don't i don't
know what's going on here i don't
understand the question okay so what
what's happening is that there comes a
point where they're they're he's pulling
her along and i would have done it a
little bit differently i would have had
her closer to me so i could always keep
an eye on her and look in her eyes make
sure she was okay and not create this
two-body problem that was one thing but
they were kind of on the end of a leash
and for some reason he you know he
decided that they couldn't survive and
that he was going to sacrifice himself
am i giving away the movie yes oh my god
but i had the same idea i would not for
two reasons number one is you don't want
to necessarily uh
you know commit suicide in space unless
you really have to and i think what i
would have done is i would have
come try to get closer to her so
i would not have to jettison myself
right okay so one thing is is that you
don't want to commit suicide the other
thing to think about is he was the more
experienced guy in that movie okay her
survival her odds of survival are much
greater if he's around he's around you
got to me and you together chuck right
we can get through the streets of
manhattan a lot better than alone this
is true you know what i'm saying or
anywhere we go out in the woods you know
we help each other right it just works
it works the opposite in the streets of
manhattan is that right i'm walking with
a white guy i'm offering you up first
all right but there's a greater chance
of you surviving
all right let's go to the woods there's
nobody else around okay i'm a dead man
we have a better okay so i can help you
but this is the point you can help me in
new york right i can help you somewhere
else exactly that makes sense you know
it's kind of like you put the mask on
your baby first that's right on yourself
first and then on your child right so
the idea is that two people together are
better than one alone and plus the
experienced guy her her chances of
surviving would have been better with
him around and that would have gone
through my mind as well is that i can
help her her she's better chance she's
gonna be around if i can stay so i don't
know why they did that you gotta have to
ask the movie guys so basically the uh
it's the um
leo dicaprio
uh and uh
what's your face on a floating board
right at the end of titanic
yes i let go
whatever yeah cause i left he was gone
already yeah he didn't look so good
right yeah at the end when i remember
but uh yeah that's maybe it was kind of
like that in this movie but i i think
you know you would you'd want to stay in
it to the bitter end and uh and try to
try to do it together because your
better chances are that way well there
you go and that's from an experienced
person who's actually been into outer
space right but i've never actually been
faced with that decision for real
but i think i would go down swinging if
i was okay all right well there you have
it buddy there's your answer there you
answer